take a guess what pronouns did they use
was he
racist
hi everyone I don't think I've done like
a general introduction yet as to who I
am so I thought I would do that now hi
my name is bunny and I use bun pronouns
so who am I I am a gender fluid trans
family teacher like passing Japanese
person I'm Cody pronouns em air errors
or zizers or really any nail pronouns
that aren't Z Hair hers I am a white
trans-masculine Femme non-binary
temporarily mostly able-bodied
neurodivergent obsessive compulsive
chronically ill culturally Jewish
Unitarian Universalist non-monogamous
demi-low romantic gray demobi sexual
Survivor of acute and complex trauma
Millennials uh that's that's the only
thing that matters Survivor of trauma
because that's the only way you get to
be that in your head
and that full of yourself that you have
to sit and label yourself and analyze
yourself to death like that and then
just carry on and on and on about
yourself the fiber of acute and complex
trauma Millennial acute and complex
trauma and mental health recovery
do you see this person next to me e is
my friend
Zeus had to put up with a lot to get to
where per is today I just want to let
Clint know that Thon is valid that for
pronouns are valid and that's their
identity is valid I I'm Ash and I'm
throwing a gender tea party where you
try out different pronouns and
honorifics to see how they feel today
I'm introducing a friend who uses am air
pronouns so this is for you if your name
is Alex or Elliot and if those aren't
your names but you like these pronouns
this one's for you too
my friend is so cool for coming to my
party it's exciting to get to know him
better I was drinking a dandelion tea
with honey to know I'm better no one
better hey I'm not I know it I know him
could use that sometimes I get you know
where I get just frustrated and I roll
my eyes and I get sad but this is
actually making me feel sad today like
right now looking at these people
thinking about the intensity of their
mental illness do you think that like do
you think herself has armpit Harrison if
I had to take a guess refill the gray
cup is heirs going on deep on it huh I
love
Eric I didn't have to dress Airsoft up
for this party but it looks great if you
like this pronounce that you can thank
them at the armpits you should be proud
of herself for trying on new pronouns
I'm proud of them
if you're non-binary and you know it
clap your hands if you're non-binary but
you're actually gender fluid but you
don't want to explain to people that
your pronouns change regularly because
your gender is that freaking fluid and
you don't really care either way what
pronouns people use except for certain
days where you feel super mask or super
fem or super androgynous
um but you also don't want to bother
people with having them try to remember
what pronouns you are for certain days
and even you don't really know most of
the day so you just sit there like
uh-huh uh-huh sure whatever you want to
reference me and this is this is how a
school shooter is made I'm sorry this
like this person is these people to over
complicate your life this much is so sad
and so depressing I'm so sad I'm sad for
their parents like how much like brain
space that takes up where you're
worrying about what what pronouns to be
called like you could be doing so many
more productive things and that's what
you're worried about it's just like I
say this all the time like the human
mind is like is um capable of incredible
things and when you fill it up with
nonsense like Tick Tock Instagram
consuming content this [ __ ] all you're
doing is putting a feeling on yourself
at all times that's all it is like like
what even is consciousness you know what
I mean like imagine you were just born
into a different Society you would just
conform to wherever you grew up you
would just become like you know the
outcome of whatever's around you your
language
so if this is just like the [ __ ] that
you you know you you feed yourself
you're just shooting yourself in the
foot this is just what you're becoming
just nonsense just becoming nonsense and
like when you it's the same [ __ ] like
when you're scrolling on Tick Tock all
day all you're doing is filling your
brain with nonsense and I do it too
sometimes I'm just like [ __ ] see it's
all right calm down yeah that's sad
crazy man sad it's sad it's sad I'm sad
for these people I really am that this
is how they're spending your life
so you all wanted to talk about how I
use my new pronouns which are D and
fairy
so here we go these are some mean
Graphics let's start off with
these would be used exactly how you
would use they them pronouns so instead
of saying that's their code you would
say that is Beast coat
or instead of saying they love
themselves you would say B loves to be
yourself next up is fairy I'm a chili
dog I'm a chili dog now chili dog loves
chili dog self yeah chili doggerson
chili dog loves chili dog self what's
wrong with that do not accept me
bigoted racist
in the same way as they then so instead
of saying that's their coat you would
say that's fairy's code again instead of
saying well you would just say if your
name was Jill you could say that's
Jill's code or that's the joke between
the B and the fairy that's B's coat
that's fairies coat see what I'm saying
it's just stupid though like this is
just not only one of the stupid ones for
watching it is just mental illness this
is just a dumb way for people to to be
spending their time what bothers me and
I'm a goddamn broken record on this is
that there are actual parents sitting
watching these videos with their
children to teach their children to be
open to this and to be more like this
and to say you can be like this too
where we used to I used to show you
videos of like Winston Churchill like
speaking you know and and or or remember
when you learned the when you memorized
the Gettysburg Address I mean you know
for school like we used to teach you to
to spend time teaching you about people
that accomplished amazing great things
on this Earth and there are parents that
are just pushing all of that aside to
teach them about my kids will grow up in
Hustler's University whatever their
grandmother is going to be there too
teaching them to not drink I said their
grandmother is going to be there too
that's me ding dong no I know but are
you in hustle's University no
no but I'm going to be there making sure
that they learn right they don't turn
into little weirdos and you better not
marry a weirdo if I ever even get
married you know you're 19. you know you
know you actually you don't know [ __ ]
that's right
ah it's too funny guy I don't know all
right can we turn this off I'm getting
Dumber I'm getting Dumber let's finish
this [ __ ] finished piece of
this video Let's fire yourself
I really hope this helps what I thought
it's I thought it's you're a b you can't
use I you can't use the singular you
can't use singular first person I you're
a B I think you can use I is I a pronoun
is I not a pronoun as a party
him
we you all them I learned that in Latin
I just don't know the Latin version I is
a pronoun
am I tripping it is a pronoun so why can
you use I you shouldn't refer to
yourself as B you should be like Trump
referring to yourself as when you're
speaking you refer to yourself as Trump
18 angry Democrats that hate president
Trump they hate him with a pet I find
that third funny [ __ ] in the world I've
tried that where I'm like I don't even
know you talk and you're like I've never
heard him say that he does it all Sunny
it would be like me saying Elena loves
pizza Sunny yeah no exactly something
like that but Donald Trump does it all
the time and I remember I tried using
that in a sentence with my own name and
I was like this sounds crazy what a guy
Trump 20 20 24.
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]